foreign
[Music]
concerns the British Monarchy the best
thing to happen to White actors since
literally everything else the monarchy
has given the world Royal weddings at
the unveiling of new Royal babies and of
course moments like this he may have
grown up in a palace but today Prince
Charles was doing his best to get in
touch with the mood on the streets oh
take that crazy Rhythm oh no no no no no
no no no
there is perhaps nothing more pathetic
than the world's most famous adult song
So Dig That Crazy rhythm with well I can
only describe as big knock energy the
monarchy is clearly in transition right
now following the death of the queen an
event that prompted 10 days of public
morning with a massive line of people
queuing for hours to pay their respects
but while some were devastated others
had more complicated feelings
the queen
it's like I can't
[Music]
tell me about the care part and then
tell me about the doctor yeah
I'll clean him it's a person who died
like sad like okay and then they don't
care about
them
yeah I get that I had a similar reaction
when big died on the Peloton I don't
care because big was pompous good for
nothing and let's be honest voted for
Trump but I do care a little because I
know that Carrie cares look at her there
in his last moments devastated doing
absolutely nothing
but their ambivalence speaks to the fact
that to a degree that Americans may not
realize the monarchy isn't a universally
beloved institution and they were being
very nice about it there others have
been much less kind in the aftermath of
the Queen's death many sporting events
held a minute silence but some crowds
particularly in Scotland and Ireland
went a different way with this song
proving particularly popular
together
[Applause]
yeah this is in a box which I know
sounds insensitive but I would argue
that of all the places they could have
chanted that she was in box is actually
pretty generous and look you can make
that is in bad taste you can also make
the case that it's very funny two things
can be true here even we got into
trouble when Sky TV in the UK cut a
couple of Fairly benign jokes that we
did the week she died who knows if this
segment will even air on TV over there
in fact just in case they refuse we've
actually prepared an alternative show
for them where this story is replaced
with a 25 minute Loop of this video of
Winston Churchill going backwards down a
water slide set to the Benny Hill theme
so they won't have nothing to watch
but in the UK the argument was that in
the wake of the Queen's death it just
wasn't the time for criticism of her or
the monarchy in general it would be
impolite but it's been two months since
then and Charles is king now and while
for many the charm of his mother was in
her longevity she was the only Sovereign
most britons had ever known and her
tendency towards silence you never
really knew what he thought about
anything neither of those things are
true of her son but
was a man whose face answers the
question what if two cousins had a kid
he's taking the throne at a ripe age of
73 he had to put it mildly and
Incredibly messy divorce and he's been
outspoken on a range of topics from
architecture to the environment to his
belief in homeopathic medicine including
supporting a controversial cancer
treatment which involves 13 Fruit juices
a day coffee enemas and weekly
injections of vitamins the point is he
doesn't have the inscrutability of his
mother or enjoy her level of public
affection at his Ascent to the throne
comes as the UK is facing a cost of
living crisis one man even recently
confronted Charles directly about this
we have to pay for your parade
foreign
[Music]
wow that befuddled oh from him pretty
much says it all there but that wasn't
the only recent protest just this week a
man threw multiple eggs at Charles on
the street and when they caught him he
didn't really seem that sorry given that
this was the photo from his arrest
he was released on bail with conditions
including and this is true not being
allowed to be within 500 meters of the
king and not being allowed to possess
any eggs in a public space
which really shows just how far the
power of the monarchy has fallen a few
hundred years ago it would have been
instant beheading now the punishment is
be careful in the refrigerated aisle
Charles is now King and will actually
have a formal coronation next May to be
beamed by cameras all around the world
before all that happens we thought
tonight it might be worth looking at the
British Monarchy specifically to ask
what the point of it is first in the UK
and then in the countries around the
world where the Monarch still serves as
a figurehead and let's start with the
very basic question of what does the
Royal Family do it's something that even
they have had trouble defining in the
past as this clip of Prince Philip from
1968 demonstrates
could you tell me
what is your job in your own mind
well I've got one I'm self-employed but
surely you must have some clear idea of
what role you fulfill in modern society
very difficult to answer
wow
it's honestly kind of amazing to watch
him initially laugh that off before
considering the question and then facing
something of an existential crisis
but since that question seemed to stump
him perhaps we can help unlike in the US
we're the head of government and the
head of state are the same person in the
UK those are two very different roles
because well for centuries the British
monarch had huge political power it was
gradually Stripped Away over the years
to the point that the position is now
largely symbolic the demonic's main role
as head of state is to receive incoming
and outgoing ambassadors and visiting
heads of state and to make visits abroad
here's the queen meeting Narendra Modi
here she has taken a carriage right with
Vladimir Putin and here she is with
former president Trump just two people
delighted to be there
yeah you don't usually see a pair so
unhappy while wearing fancy costumes
outside of cats on Halloween
there are also smaller responsibilities
they do too like visiting factories and
opening things and also and this is true
sending people birthday cards when they
turn 100 basically think of the Royals
as Mickey and Minnie at Disneyland
they're not running the rides but
they're a mascot for the whole operation
and people kind of like having their
pictures taken with them and the Royal
Family's Defenders will say that the
ceremonial aspect of the monarchy is
really the whole point in fact the Royal
Family's official website describes the
role of sovereign as a focus for
national identity unity and pride and
that it gives a sense of stability and
continuity but that comes at a price as
you heard that man yell earlier
Britain's pay millions of pounds every
year to support the Royals although some
will argue that it's actually money well
spent
interestingly the British State gives or
the government gives the royal family
100 million pounds per year roughly it's
called The Sovereign Grant to pay for
upkeep but tourism generated by the
royal family generates about 500 million
a year so that's five to one I would
take I would take that investment return
right The monarchy's Defenders argue
that whatever money the royal family
cost is vastly outweighed by what they
bring in it's the exact same argument
thousands of men have made to their
wives about investing in crypto and it's
going really well for them right now but
a few things about that first the claim
that they bring in 500 million a year in
tourism is heavily disputed and it is
not like that goes away if the royal
family does you can still visit a palace
if nobody lives inside it no one shows
up to Versailles and says wait no one
lives here it's a hard pass from me
and the notion that the monarchy only
costs 100 million pounds also has some
major asterisks on it because while it
is true that as is often said The
Sovereign Grant amounts to just over a
pound a person in the UK it's by no
means the Royals only source of income
the new king now has three main sources
of wealth The Sovereign grant money the
UK treasury gives the crown to fulfill
its Royal duties the family's private
wealth the full extent of closely
guarded secret then the duchy of
Lancaster a private estate of land
property and assets the Monarch receives
its annual profits the queen received 27
million dollars from it last year it's
true the duchy of Lancaster is a massive
property portfolio containing land that
incidentally was seized by the monarchy
back in the 13th century after which
they continue to draw personal profits
to this day so as King Charles gets
money from the government money passed
down through his family and money from
the duchy of Lancaster and none of that
includes the duchy of Cornwall held by
whoever holds the title of Prince of
Wales it used to be Charles now it's
Prince William that is a separate
billion dollar real estate portfolio
nearly the size of Chicago by the way
which includes Seaside vacation rentals
office space in London and a Suburban
Supermarket Depot that alone brought in
26 million in additional income for the
family last year so the Royal Family's
wealth unlike their gene pool is massive
and while in 1993 in response to public
anger over their spending both the queen
and Charles agreed to pay voluntary
income taxes that Arrangement isn't
necessarily permanent meanwhile the two
duchies are completely exempt from
Corporation taxes and Charles doesn't
have to pay any inheritance tax on
whatever the queen passed on to him and
when you factor all of that in it sure
starts to feel like they're costing a
hell of a lot more than just a pound per
person so is it worth it well people can
disagree I think my position on the
royal family is pretty well documented
to me they're like a human appendix
we've long evolved past needing them and
there's a compelling case for their
surgical removal but I admit I am in the
minority when it comes to British people
many feel exactly like this woman does I
just think it's nice that we have it and
it makes us a bit unusual unique
yeah I mean it's nice that we have it
it's a British thing isn't it and I
think a lot of people would like what we
have
okay but but it's nice that we have it
isn't what you say about a freeloading
multi-millionaire family exempt from
paying most taxes it's what you say
about a water dispenser in your fridge
ask for being a British thing that's not
a great justification either you know
what else is a British thing mushy peace
if you've never had the pleasure imagine
emotionally unavailable guacamole
they're like if mashed potatoes killed
themselves but the fact is 67 of people
in the UK feel that the monarchy should
remain so for now it does seem secure
there but that brings us to the second
part of this story because abroad their
role is a much more open question
Charles as king is now head of the
Commonwealth of Nations a loose Alliance
a largely composed of former British
colonies 14 of which still have the
British monarch as their titular Head of
State in spite of being self-ruling
Nations these are those countries and
debates have been raging for a while in
many of them about what the crown
represents as we mentioned back in March
William and Kate had to cancel the first
stop on their Royal tour through the
Caribbean due to overwhelming local
protests and in Australia in the wake of
the Queen's death the women's Aussie
Rules Football League held a moment of
silence for her but given that they were
by sheer coincidence in the midst of a
10-day tribute to indigenous players
they opted not to do that for the rest
of the morning period prompting this man
to freak out what a disgrace seriously I
mean that that any sporting organization
in this country would think there is any
reason not to honor the queen is a joke
and why can't they have a minute silence
in indigenous week anyway I mean it you
know indigenous people are Australian
people they were subjects of her majesty
the queen and you can have your
arguments about colonialism or whatever
but the queen in this country and for
the world was a forceful good what
you can't just gloss over the entire
history of colonialism there it's like
saying have all the arguments about
murder or whatever but at the end of the
day Charles Manson was a family man
let's talk about that history starting
in Australia where indigenous people
suffered greatly under colonial rule
researchers have found evidence for
conservatively nearly 200 massacres of
Aboriginal people at the hands of
British Military and Colonial police and
hundreds more by colonists and when the
queen herself visited Australia in 1954
First Nations people were not counted as
part of the population and children were
still being forcibly removed from their
families to be assimilated into white
households so have your arguments about
colonialism or whatever is very much
what we should be doing not glossing
over it and forcing people to mourn a
symbol of a painful past and that's just
Australia if you really want to talk
about colonialism or whatever or
litigate the extent to which the queen
or the monarchy in general has been a
global Force for good let's do that and
let's start with the full extent to
which the monarchy was intricately
involved in the transatlantic slave
trade after Britain invaded Jamaica in
1655 the Royal African company was set
up by Royal Charter under King Charles
II the RAC went on to transport more
enslaved Africans to the Americas than
any other single institution ever lining
the pockets of the Stuart monarchs many
of those trafficked were branded with
the initials DUI as in the Duke of York
who led the company and later became
King James II that's true the direct
ancestors of today's royal family were
investors in the Royal African company
and had their initials literally branded
into people's skin and both the trade of
enslaved people and the high demand
products that they produced like sugar
and tobacco went to enriching Britain
strengthening its Empire and by
extension filling Royal coffers and I do
get the people shouldn't be held
personally responsible for whatever
their ancestors did but trying to talk
about the British role in the slave
trade without talking about the monarchy
it's sort of like trying to talk about
Jeffrey Epstein without talking about
about the monarchy they are inextricably
linked however uncomfortable they might
find that fact
yet despite all of that no one in the
royal family has ever apologized on
behalf of the crown instead they've
tiptoed around culpability with passive
voice statements like Prince William
saying slavery was abhorrent or Prince
Charles going to Ghana and saying this
the appalling atrocity of the slave
trade
and the unimaginable suffering it caused
left an indelible stain on the history
of our world
while Britain can be proud that he'd
later led the way in the abolition of
this shameful trade
we have shared a responsibility we have
a shared responsibility to ensure that
the abject horror of slavery is never
forgotten
but listen to that he can't even mention
how awful the slave trade was without in
the same breath mentioned that Britain
led the way in abolishing it British
people love to talk about their role in
abolition but Charles left out a lot
there including that while yes the
British did abolish the slave trade in
1807 it allowed Plantation slavery to
persist in colonies for decades after
meaning full abolition didn't follow for
another generation but the larger Point
here is you can't have it both ways you
don't get to take the credit for
abolition without taking the blame for
what led up to it if someone
intentionally set fire to a Quiznos then
hours later put that fire out they
wouldn't get to post a picture of
themselves holding a hose with a caption
so I did a thing that's not the full
story is it
also for what it's worth the effect of
slavery clearly isn't just in the past
the UK was paying for it in a very
literal sense incredibly recently
because when Britain finally abolished
slavery in its colonies in the 1830s it
took out a loan of 20 million pounds but
not to compensate enslaved people
instead it went to enslavers who wanted
compensation for the loss of income from
their properties which to be clear meant
people that is about 17 billion pounds
in today's money and up until 2015 the
British state was still paying off the
debt amazingly many learned about this
for the first time when a few years ago
the British treasury tweeted here's
today's surprising hashtag Friday fact
millions of you helped end the slave
trade through your taxes and I'm sorry
but that is just not a good Friday fact
the average person farts between 10 to
20 times per day that is pretty good
fish can cough now we're talking
surprise I know times are tough but you
just helped pay off the families of dead
enslavers no absolutely [ __ ] not save
that [ __ ] for Monday you buzz kill
and for anyone thinking well that didn't
happen on the watch of the modern
monarchy it is worth knowing one of the
most brutal atrocities carried out by
the British actually happened in the
first eight years of Elizabeth's Reign
and when Charles was alive because in
the 1950s while Kenya was still a
British colony an armed rebellion was
launched by the kakuyu people who had
lost land to White settlers and found
themselves locked into a formal racial
hierarchy that place Europeans on top
and Africans at the bottom the British
sent Army reinforcements to put down the
so-called Mao Mao Uprising describing
the situation to the world back then
like this agitators urged some of the
Africans to free their country of the
white man
there is little reliable information
about the setup of the terrorist
organization for few members even know
from whom they take their orders they
obey blindly savagely attacking the
defenseless burning looting murdering
Kenya is the battlefield of a conflict
that cannot end until the Mao Mao is
dissolved forever
alrighty how the troubling Kenya comes
not from the British who took over and
stole land but from the people whose
land were stolen now is there more to
this story surely but will you hear it
coming from a voice that sounds like
this I Say Never
Never I say in crushing the uprising the
British instituted a system of detention
camps and 90 000 Kenyans were executed
tortured or maimed during the Crackdown
and an estimated 160 000 were detained
in appalling conditions for a long time
the British met outcry over this with a
mixture of denial and defensiveness in
fact just watch this interview with a
former British colonial officer who'd
been responsible for at least six of
those detention camps when asked about
reports that soldiers had put their
boots on the necks of detainees he has
an escalating exchange culminating in
the single longest pause you will ever
see on television I'll warn you however
long you think this pause is going to be
it's going to be much longer did you
have cause to give the order to yourself
put your boot on their neck
of these resistors the ones that were
howling
um can we stop talking for a moment no
because I'd quite like you to answer
that I will answer it when I have
stopped talking for a moment
um
I'm sorry but I I well do you have a
problem with that question no it's um
it's a
hypothetical question no it's not it's a
very precise you asked me did I put my
foot on anybody's neck no did you cause
the order to be given did you give the
order to do that
are you not going to answer the question
no I'm looking at you with um
certain thoughts in my mind
your role in
sick torture here's a few quick tips
don't respond to a simple question by
taking a full 23 seconds to answer don't
then issue a vague threat like some kind
of cartoon villain and finally try not
to glare malevolently at the interview
with what I can only describe as War
crime eyes
and just to be clear we don't know what
the queen knew what she is briefed on is
kept secret very conveniently but we do
know what was done in her name by her
government her face was on the money in
Kenya when kenyan's captors sang their
national anthem it was a hymn to her
protection and we do know that she was
not only characteristically silent about
those atrocities you know in that
Charming style that everybody loved but
she also awarded that man an MBE one of
the country's highest honors which is
just appalling unless the MBE stands for
messiest [ __ ] ever in which case yeah I
guess I guess that might be appropriate
and that is the thing if you are the
symbol of a country you represent what
it does and it is revealing that even
decades later when the British finally
agreed to pay some compensation to a
fraction of those who suffered in Kenya
this woman was very clear about who she
wanted to hear from
is one of the few surviving Memorial
Independence fighters in Kenya Britain
has apologized for some abysses but
matenge did not get a compensation paid
to other Rebels she's calling on the
queen for help before it's too late
let Elizabeth bring what belongs to me
that's what I want to say no middlemen
in between let the compensation come
directly to me she should look for a
sensible person and send it here yeah
that's completely understandable and
particularly the send a sensible person
point because when you are dealing with
the royal family it's very much worth
remembering that unless you stipulate
otherwise you could end up being sent
someone like this
oh take that crazy Rhythm exactly and
nobody wants that nobody
the point is you can't say you're just a
symbol and bear no responsibility for
that how the institutions that you are
the head of behave take the Church of
England of which the Monarch is the head
in Canada it played a role in their
system of residential schools for
indigenous children who are forcibly
separated from their families and sent
to government-funded church-run boarding
schools in an attempt to assimilate them
horrific abuses happened in those
schools and while they were largely run
by the Catholic church the church of
England operated approximately three
dozen of them giving up control of the
last one in 1969 which is pretty [ __ ]
recent early this year Charles visited
Canada and made a point of showing up in
a garden that paid tribute to the
victims of those schools but when it
came to showing remorse for what had
happened that seemed to be off the table
because just listen to One indigenous
leader who briefly spoke with Charles
that day describe their entire Exchange
you did say
um I hope we were too bad on you I
didn't get a chance to respond to be
moved on the prince Wally in this
country you should apologize to their
American people for the for the trauma
that we've gone to for 500 years
wow I hope we weren't too bad on you he
said before
walking away which I know seem bad to
you
but honestly pretty on brand you keep
calm and now if you'll excuse me I will
carry on
and look I know across commonwealth
countries there are a range of views on
this especially among the older
generation as incredibly even some who
suffered under British rule can still
feel strong affection for the queen
personally even if they didn't love what
she represented and some argue if the
royal family is just ceremonial now
where is the real harm but the
ceremonial can still have the power to
infuriate and to see that let's go back
to Australia because shortly before the
queen died Lydia Thorpe an indigenous
Australian Senator was taking the oath
of office which required her to swear
allegiance to the queen something she
understandably had a bit of a problem
with so this is what she did please
recite the affirmation on the card
handed to you
I
Sovereign Lydia thought
through solemnly and sincerely
that I will be faithful when I bear True
Religion
to the colonizing Her Majesty Queen
Elizabeth Senator Thorpe Senator thought
you are required to recite the oath as
printed on the card yeah they actually
forced her to read what was printed on
the card verbatim so she did that but
credit to her because she then employed
a tone of voice that did a lot of heavy
lifting for her I really have thought
do solemnly and sincerely affirm and
declare
that I will be faithful and Bear
true allegiance to her majesty Queen
Elizabeth II
her hairs and successes according to law
okay I hate that she was forced to do
that but I absolutely love the way that
she was able to make a pledge to a fancy
old lady on the other side of the world
sound exactly as stupid as it [ __ ] is
and look to go by recent polls Australia
like the UK seems unlikely to let go of
the monarchy anytime soon but other
commonwealth countries are already
preparing to do so last year Barbados
removed the queen as head of state
Jamaica is looking to have a referendum
to do the same within the next three
years with one poll showing a majority
supported and Antigua and Barbuda
Grenada and Belize seem to be moving in
the same direction and while the royal
family has said that these countries are
free to leave if they so choose they
also refuse to reckon with why they
might want to do that in the first place
instead they've continued working hard
to be perceived as a mere symbol while
never taking responsibility for what
that symbol excused all while ignoring
calls for True apologies and reparations
to those who suffered tremendously
because of what was done in their name
and look you don't have to hate the
royal family personally I mean Google
Prince Philip racism or prince Andrew
everything and see where he lands but
you don't have to hate them
you don't even have to think that the
institution shouldn't exist but if it's
going to continue to it is fair to
expect significantly more from them
because right now far too often they
hide behind the convenient Shield of
politeness and manners which frequently
demands The Silence of anyone who might
criticize them or what they stand for
will this segment even air on Sky TV in
Britain I honestly don't know maybe
maybe not but if they do cut it out for
being disrespectful they might want to
seriously think about why why they and
everyone else are working so hard not to
offend a family whose name was branded
into people's skin and who sit atop a
pile of stolen wealth wearing crowns
adorned with other countries treasures
and if there is an answer to that I
would love to hear it though if history
is any guide I'm guessing I'm just going
to get an icy stare while you think
certain thoughts in your head
but I really hope that they don't cut
this piece partly because this is a long
overdue conversation that really needs
to be had and partly because absolutely
no audience deserves to be subjected to
25 straight minutes of this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
that's our show thanks so much for
watching we'll see you next week good
night